any any facts that come out about this
case are just absolutely disgusting
and you know it just knows what kind of
person he was i think
the the shame of it is at the moment
that the police seem to be trying to
distance themselves by saying that no
one saw him as a police officer he was a
police officer there's no like that is a
fact there's no um getting away from
that you know
yeah they've actually said uh they do
not view mr cousins as a police officer
um from what you're saying there patsy
you you feel that you can't accept that
and and they're shirking their
responsibility well i think there's a
complete lack of accountability within
the police um
you know he was a police officer so that
the fact that they're trying to distance
themselves from that it just i think
they know that the trust has been
um diminished within the police force
because they are there to protect and
serve that's their whole purpose
and they're not protecting women and
girls at all they're actually doing
quite the opposite and at the moment
we've got like the policing bill is
going forward which only gives them more
powers which i don't understand why this
is still going through you know
so what do you want the police to do to
try to make people like you and so many
other people that took part in that
demonstration back in my or the vigil
let's say back in march what do the
police need to do to make you feel safer
on the street
there needs to be a whole you know the
first thing is accountability the first
thing is them holding their hands up and
saying you know what this this happened
because of the way our our force is and
because within the met police they have
racism they have sexism they have
misogyny you hear about it all the time
i've spoken to ex-police officers um who
have left the force because of those
reasons um you know i'm i'm quite i'm
disappointed in increasing dick because
you know she is a woman and but just
because she's a woman doesn't mean that
she's going to stop um misogyny within
the force she can be misogynistic
herself even as a woman um and when
you're in that
when you're in that system yourself um a
lot of a lot of people that work in that
system become they have to become this
um
you know one one with their peers and
and
and sort of
have have
faiths that can be misogynistic just to
get along with their colleagues even
is she the right person for the job
i mean
i i don't think so at all i'm i'm
shocked that she got a two-year
extension but there's many things behind
that but yeah i i don't know
how she can still have the job when so
many things have still so many things
have happened um you know it's not just
about vigil it's about women's safety
it's about all the people who have died
in police custody there's there's so
many issues within the net police at the
moment
that i just i feel like at every point
they are just ignoring
people who have concerns and that's why
they're diminishing the trust themselves
they're doing this themselves
they had as many checks and balances in
place as possible that's what we're
hearing from the government minister
this morning
and every organization will have a bad
apple they did everything they could um
to try to
weed out people like wayne cousins and
sadly he got through the system yeah so
i mean why was he allowed to become just
remain a police officer when he was gone
for indecent exposure a few days before
i mean so when they say we've done
everything possible they clearly didn't
they clearly aren't because they're
still an issue um when they say one bad
apple again it's like they're trying to
distance themselves um you know the good
apples allowed it to happen so they're
really good apples are they you know
just as bad
you're going to have a demonstration or
taking part in a protest at the old
bailey today tell us more about that
it's only a possibility i know that um
you know a lot of the this is the shame
that
you know the government need to be
protecting us but unfortunately the
the
responsibility always comes down to
communities and organizations and
activists that i've now seen and work
with and they are tirelessly trying to
fight against violence against um male
violence against women and girls
and they are doing everything in their
power
and i think if they had um you know the
same amount of power as the government
did we might actually see some change
um
so you know that's why we do protest
that's why that's why people stand up
for the human rights every single day
and unfortunately as well you don't
always see about it on the news i didn't
know about half of this stuff before the
vigil happened i was you know just a
student at the university i'd only ever
been to one um protest in my life which
is a black lives matter protest um but
i'd never
think of what happened in activism and
now i've seen it i think the women that
are doing this work are absolutely
incredible they really are fighting for
everyone's rights and they don't get any
recognition for it